see and they get they can throw shade
you know shading that's what they do
just shade shade shade now it's funny
when I say things when I say things like
you're a shitty wife if you don't sleep
with your husband if you don't cook you
don't clean you divorce him a good wife
is gonna say yeah that's pretty shitty
to do and not sleep with him not cook
not clean and then divorce him after
it's like and take half and take the
kids it's like a good loyal wife is
gonna say yeah I agree but a bad wife
the one that's gonna get mad a bad wife
is the one that's gonna be like well but
there's the exception there's this far
off situation that could happen you
don't have any experience
you you shouldn't be the one talking
about it and I'm just like water is wet
water is wet it's not really rocket
science it's actually quite basic you
know